Indian guy with a fun ass shirt fun ass
white girl I see you okay go ahead what
you for a
little that's what this is huh trying to
run from who you are certain parts of
you are so American and then certain
parts of you are so Indian and I don't
mean that racially I'm not talking about
skin tone I'm saying like you got this
white girl here you got this
floral shirt on unbutton couple buttons
being sexy to the world and with this
floral dress shirt you have on a Puma
hat and flipflops that's so Indian I got
many a shirt like this I'm not knocking
the shirt I'm knocking the fact that you
need to pick what the you are your
Indian from the kneecaps down don't make
no sense to me